n it's it's dope to see everything going
on with you man obviously the last time
you were on the show was not too far
after we launched the show I mean it was
maybe like four or five months after we
launched the podcast yeah um it's been a
minute man it's been a minute that was
like kind of right after you had um not
right after you had left NE but I guess
you had kind of broken your silence it
was right after you dropped the first
YouTube video
kind of talking about of the new like
direction of content that you were doing
yeah um and I don't think I've I sold
the company at that point though no you
didn't I was like that is correct
because shortly after that we had me and
you had started collabing on some pranks
um we had some of the best dude best
episodes we ever did was I get stopped
all the time really and they're always
like dude the prank with the guy who who
wrapped like a bear and and and and a a
koifish and and Simba my boy you know
Simba who's huge you know at the time he
was on the come up he still was on the
come up but he's a lot bigger than he
was then he even brings that [__] up to
me he'll be like dude that [__] was
crazy like people still ask me about
like about that whole situation really
there was a Snow the Product one we did
that for whatever reason that was with
Steve right it was with Steve and for
whatever reason the like real version of
that prank did not
drop I think I don't know was it cuz it
was I think it was like we shot it as a
milk video well that's what I was going
to say I I think you guys had shot
something and I think at that at that
time that was like a situation where
Steve was in it and I think they they
the real footage of that was supposed to
possibly come out on nek yeah but we had
like a kind of a diet version oh I think
I know what happened that was around um
cuz like me and Kyle were kind of
shooting our own things anyways it
wasn't very public but like yeah so the
idea was towing cars as a prank and so I
went to you and we shot that we brought
Steve and we had a segment we were going
to do for the video but then I think
they got sued or someone got I think
like the team got arrested for that
prank I think that and then that's they
couldn't upload the footage or or they
couldn't finish so there's like really
dope footage of this Snow the Product
prank that we'll never see the light of
day but it was really good I got on some
drives probably she had like her Jeep
was hooked onto a tow truck and she was
trying to back out wheel were spinning
and she's like freaking out she has her
girlfriend in the car and uh I think
Steve was just saying the most
disrespectful sexist [__] to this it was
hilarious it was so
funny he was like talking about like
well yeah I know girls can't drive I
mean you're a woman oh that's what it
was yeah yeah it was it was Peak Peak
Steve will do we can't let you drive
because you're a woman 100% it was it
was good man um it that that's what I
was going to say say man recently
obviously uh it was so awesome to
see uh obviously the long way everybody
ever since the full send podcast launch
was waiting on you to go on there so it
was dope to see you guys chat and kind
of talk about um the good old days and
some of the early pranks that you guys
had and then they kind of you gave it a
listen yeah I watched the whole thing
yeah I think the day dropped uh and then
I watched the uh the New York one where
you guys were security guards oh yeah
yeah very it just was like
nostalgic I get a lot of people have me
up since that video and been like yeah
it was like the perfect nostalgic thing
to do together that like brought back
like cuz a lot of people I think they
they got brought into NK because of that
Coachella video we did so it was like
their like first [__] thing they seen
so they were just stoked to see that
yeah I just like I think that that's
what I miss you guys I just miss that
kind of content because it doesn't
really exist anymore and I don't think
Kyle's focused on making that kind of
[__] anymore and so it was just dope to
see you know what I mean feeding off
each other kind of yeah and just you
know like I I I I just think some of you
guys' pranks were just some of the best
[__] like you guys would really like you
know whether it's you and and uh Steve
obviously Steve's face I don't even
think it'd be shown anywhere on YouTube
from what I've heard right not even his
hand man it's [__] sad not even his
hand apparently I heard that yeah was
talk about doing a podcast with him or
something and like and he be off camera
and like or that's what it was I think
he did the Donald Trump one or something
happened and his hand was in it and they
were like flagging it and it was like
what it's [__] Bonkers dude that poor
guy man I really feel bad for him
because like he such a sweet dude dude
and he was doing so much like look he
was doing some like pushing the limit
type [__] but he also was giving away so
much money to like random families like
I remember he had that random lady he
was taking on the road with him
everywhere the black chick like I always
thought I mean I I I miss him on YouTube
I haven't checked them out on Rumble to
see if the pranks or the videos are
still of of uh the quality that they
were but yeah when you're deplatformed
it's hard to I don't know
like I think it was cuz it was his like
audio but then they were like oh it's
not in it and then they said no like I
think they used like his hand being in
it I could be [__] wrong but I
remember hearing that somewhere but